soft on crime consequences showing up
again this time in sunday's deadly
shooting in sacramento that left six
people dead and a dozen others injured
police arresting smiley martin who was
released from prison just weeks ago the
career criminal was out on parole six
years early from his 10-year sentence
for a brutal assault on his girlfriend
the d.a adamantly opposed his release
writing this in a letter to the parole
board quote
inmate martin clearly has little regard
for human life and the law if he is
released early he will continue to break
the law that's pretty clear but despite
that they let martin walk free
california gubernatorial candidate
michael schellenberger knows who's at
fault quote
responsibility for the mass shooting
which killed a homeless woman lies with
governor gavin newsom who appointed the
head of the department california
department of corrections which already
reduced california's prison population
by nearly 30 000 inmates since 2019 and
get this and is seeking to reduce it by
an additional 76 000
which means not only is it going to get
worse california's leaders know that
it's going to get worse and they're not
going to do a damn thing about it so
judge how can they con this is what gets
me they knew when they released the 30
000 they called it like collateral
damage uh i can't remember which d.a
might have been gascoigne was saying
that like you know it's good there's
going to be people that are going to
reoffend right you got 70 000 people can
they stop this
is it probably not because you know the
d.a in the case that you referenced with
smiley martin and i spoke to her she's a
friend of mine anne-marie schubert said
we did everything we could to keep this
guy in jail he's a prior violent felon
he was convicted again of a felony he
got a 10 year sentence in 2018 and then
all of a sudden they give him and she
said janine it's not early parole this
is not parole this is just a
pay-per-review right they just come up
with it they make the law as they go
along they do it on paper and they
decide i said but wait a minute did they
give him good time what did he do she
said they make up good time there is
lawlessness on the west coast right now
we are in the wild west this guy had a
fully automa automatic machine gun he
was fully auto and a hundred bullets in
a civilized society it's not going to
end until we take the people out who
believe in all of this social justice
nonsense because social justice to me if
this is social justice it's it equates
with attacking american citizens
geraldo i'm not a lawyer although i have
pretended to be one uh
why can't there be like a class action
suit by victims families you know
because that could sue
sue the this stated at bankruptcy that
seems to me to be one solution i don't
know any that have succeeded many have
tried because they they make for a big
first day big headline but then they go
nowhere they get eaten up in school i
mean in uh in overtime
what i want to talk about is uh
remember super predators during the
clinton administration
you know those who commit crimes without
remorse without regard to the
consequences either to the victim or
even to themselves and then we went to
this uh you know with different kind of
reformist kind of uh with shorter
sentences low or no bail uh trauma
trying to move away from the uh the fact
that america is the the country with the
largest per capita population in prison
and try to to remedy that what if
there is a such a thing
such a super predator i submit to you
that smiley martin as as you describe
him judge with the record that he had
with the remorseless violence with the
the savage uh relationship he had with
the the woman in his life and the fact
that uh he he spent his time as soon as
he got out of prison working on a on a
weapon to make it a full automatic and
then the first provocation in this club
whatever it is an altercation apparently
then starts mowing people down killing
six innocent people including a homeless
woman what if there are super predators
what if the social scientists of recent
past have aired horribly
and made a misjudgment here
about human nature that we're all
suffering the consequences
that's a good point and i think you know
jesse yesterday i brought up the fact
that how the left is known for
compassion but you hear the victims were
mostly minority one was a homeless woman
and but they're victims of liberal
policies they are and you're never gonna
get answers from these people they'll
hide this guy was a pimp he beat up his
girlfriend the girlfriend was turning
tricks for him and he chased her out
into the street punched her in the face
then whipped her with a belt she ran
back inside the closet and he beat her
up again this guy's a bad dude and
newsom appointed the parole board that
let this guy out these are all
hand-picked people by newsom and you get
the ideology from the department of
corrections lady again a newsome
appointee
her name is kathleen allison and she
wants to let out 76 000 more inmates and
the correctional officers union are
suing her because this is so dangerous
her biography on the website she brags
about expedited release of inmates
and she says we're now at the lowest
prison population in 30 years like
that's a good thing
she also says on the website that her
focus is on rehabilitation and
restorative justice so there you go she
doesn't even call them prisoners or
felons on the website they say in
california they call them incarcerated
people that's what we're dealing with
here so the whole government in
california is infected with these
liberal ideologues they're infested it's
not just gavin it's all the little
people that he plugs in through
patronage and all these boards and all
these places and they're the ones making
these horrible decisions and it's
costing people's lives yeah it's uh in
in true justice these early releases
should go and move in with the people
that have them released absolutely that
would be you know you know remember that
i think we covered it where homeless
people were allowed to live with other
they should do that with these releases
san francisco yes that's what they
should do with people like this well you
bring up michael shellenberger and he is
actually running for a governor in
california so it's um there there will
be an option a choice in a couple of
years you could have a reasonable person
he's not a right-wing fringe candidate
this is a democrat and he was registered
independent and then he said that he dug
into the issues he wanted to understand
why the policies weren't working and he
has come to different conclusions about
how to lead and he does a lot about for
drug addicts as well
the california government is in breach
of contract with its citizens so to your
point like so could you sue yeah um it
would be a an interesting thing to see
the other one point i wanted to make is
that you know immediately that day we
had the statements from joe biden and
others saying we need gun control
immediately and as i've said and i i i
but then there's they never
put out statements when you find out
what happened
and who the
suspect is and that he was has prior
convictions and that he was let out
early you never hear anybody say
anything about cover-up it's basically a
cover-up for their own flaws well
there's also something called sovereign
immunity you know that would be a
defense in many of these cases you know
you could sue for malicious prosecution
because the prosecutor was malicious and
prosecuting right but to go in on the
other end and say they're not doing
enough or to protect the citizenry
that's where you run into you know of
sovereign immunity where the government
has a defense yeah we're in the
government you can't sue us uh i
remember biden in the 90s was very tough
on christ yeah but you know he had a
change of heart he does he forgot yeah
he did free he forgot i was being
facetious but you know when you bring up
shellenberger i think it's a this has to
be hung around gavin newsom's neck and
and i think schellenberger is probably
the most exciting political candidate
i've seen in a long time and he
unlike he he identifies the problems but
he wrote two books with solutions yeah
they're in there so i mean i think that
newsom has got to pay for this and i and
people in california should look at
shellenberger uh and uh if you don't
like me uh just discount my opinion
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else